Dann sollen die Hamburger den Antrag stellen, wir spielen ohne Ball. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Schwollo, außer bei dem Freistoß irgendwann noch mal den Ball gehabt hat in der zweiten Halbzeit. Und ich bin deshalb sauer, weil ich sage, wenn eine Mannschaft nicht im Rhythmus ist, dann einverstanden, 0-0, wieder Sicherheit, ein Punkt. Aber nicht, wenn du so gut gespielt hast – gegen Hoffenheim zahlen – und wirklich in einer Art und Weise gespielt hast, auch mit Angriffspressing, wie wir es analysiert haben, und dann hier so auftritt, dann ist das für mich einfach für die Bundesliga zu wenig. Und ich weiß, nochmals kann sich auch jeder aufregen. Ich respektiere das auch, aber das hat mit Fußball nichts zu tun.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Wen habt ihr da im Intro gehört? Ihr habt es natürlich erkannt, Matthias Sammer und Jan Henkel, Letzterer aber nur ganz kurz zu hören. Das war einer der seltenen Momente, in denen Matthias Sammer mal richtig deutlich Kritik an einer Mannschaft geübt hat, aber so wie man ihn kennt in der Eurosport-Berichterstattung, taktisch fundiert und dann auch mit einer sachlichen Basis. Und genau darum soll es in diesem Tribünengespräch gehen. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Hackebos, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und ich freue mich sehr, euch diese 19. Ausgabe des Rasenfunk-Tribünengesprächs zu präsentieren mit zwei ganz besonderen Gästen, Jan Henkel und Matthias Sammer. Also die beiden Protagonisten dieses Intros, die bei Eurosport eine bemerkenswerte Berichterstattung rund um die Fußball-Bundesliga aufziehen, haben sich Zeit für den Rasenfunk genommen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Eurosport dafür. Es war eine große Freude, dieses Gespräch zu führen. Das hier zeichne ich jetzt vorab auf, damit einfach von der Sendezeit mit den beiden nichts verloren geht. Ich möchte da nicht eine Minute Intro verlieren. Deswegen hört ihr mich jetzt quasi hier im Vorlauf und gleich geht es los mit dem Gespräch. Vorher möchte ich noch ein Danklos werden und zwar an Clancy, Guido, Fahne, Philipp Schneider, Michael und Fabian. You're the man and you know it. Warum danke ich all diesen Menschen? Weil sie Rasenfunk-Supporter sind. Was sind Rasenfunk-Supporter? Rasenfunk-Supporter sind diejenigen, die das hier am Laufen halten. Der Rasenfunk ist werbefrei, sponsorenfrei. Es gibt keine Payballs. Es gibt nur Unterstützung durch die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Beziehungsweise, was heißt nur, das ist eigentlich die schönste Finanzierungsform, wenn ihr mich fragt. Das ermöglicht es uns, dass wir solche Sendungen wie diese hier produzieren. Der Plan ist, den Rasenfunk hauptberuflich zu machen und damit dann auch unsere Spieltagszusammenfassungen in der Schlusskonferenz zu finanzieren, unsere Kurzpässe. Es wird zur WM tägliche Kurzpässe geben. Da könnt ihr euch schon drauf freuen. Deswegen vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns jetzt schon supporten und an alle diejenigen, die es vielleicht das jetzt zum Anlass nehmen, das zu tun. Unter rasenfunk.de unterstützen erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Monetär freuen wir uns natürlich sehr und kleine Beträge helfen schon. Kleine Beträge helfen schon. Wenn jeder von euch nur ein Euro gibt, dann wären wir schon lange durchfinanziert und dann würden die Gäste auch schon einen Honorar bekommen. Das ist dann Schritt Nummer zwei. Also schaut euch das an und ihr könnt uns auch anders unterstützen, und zwar indem ihr einfach weiter erzählt, dass es den Rasenfunk gibt, dass ihr vielleicht auch diese Folge hier empfehlt. Auch mal in andere Folgen reinhört, sollte das jetzt die erste sein, die ihr hört, also gerade so eine Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz zum Bundesliga-Spieltag. Da könnt ihr dann mal auf Wahrheit abklopfen, ob das, was ich gleich mit Jan Henkel und Matthias Sammer bespreche, ob sich das wirklich auch im Rasenfunk so wiederfindet. Und natürlich könnt ihr auch mal in die Kurzpässe reinhören. Empfehlt uns gerne weiter. Ihr könnt uns sehr gerne Rezensionen bei iTunes schreiben. Das hilft uns auch sehr. Bevorzugt natürlich positive Rezensionen. Aber wer wäre ich, euch da irgendwelche Vorgaben zu machen? Ihr wisst das schon am besten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich würde sagen, das reicht auch jetzt der Vorrede. Wollen wir mit dem Gespräch starten? Ich denke ja. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei. Aber jetzt legen wir los mit Matthias Sammer und Jan Henkel. Und bitte. Matthias Sammer, Jan Henkel, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Die erste Podcastaufzeichnung ist eine Ehre, dass der Rasenfunk da Nummer eins sein darf. Ich habe gerade schon so ein bisschen erzählt, wie der Rasenfunk gestaltet ist und dass wir auch keine Längenvorgabe haben. Herr Henkel, was muss ich denn machen, damit Matthias Sammer so richtig ins Reden kommt? Ist das wirklich so, dass sie dann nicht zu bremsen sind? Denn den Eindruck gewinnt man bei der Sendung, die sie machen, bei Eurosport immer wieder auch. Manchmal ist es eher die Schwierigkeit, sie zu bremsen, als sie loszuschieben.
Na ja, Fußball ist erst einmal Liebe, Leidenschaft und eine starke Identität, die man dafür hat. Wir haben bei Eurosport die Voraussetzungen bekommen, auch das so dann aufzuzeigen und die Sendung auch so zu gestalten mit Jan Henkel, wie es vielleicht im ursprünglichen Fußball mal war. Und das gefällt mir und die entsprechenden Themen dann richtig gesetzt und in der Vorbereitung. Es gibt ja heute wunderbare Module, wo wir uns alles anschauen können. Das macht Freude. Und es ist völlig uninteressant, ob der FC Bayern gegen Borussia Dortmund spielt oder Mainz gegen Wolfsburg, weil über den Fußball zu reden und die Inhalte dann auch in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen. Diese Möglichkeit haben wir.
Woher kam denn eigentlich die Entscheidung, das so aufzuziehen?
Das war eine grundsätzliche Idee. Ich erzähle immer ganz gerne die Geschichte, dass ich vor, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Monate das mittlerweile her ist, hatte schon schon ein deutliches Gespräch mit Julian Nagelsmann hatte. Und er ja speziell ist in seiner Sprachgeschwindigkeit, in der Wortwahl, in der Art und Weise, wie er über Fußball redet. Und ich bin irgendwann ausgestiegen und habe gesagt, ich verstehe es nicht, Julian, ich verstehe dich nicht mehr. Und das fand ich für mich ziemlich frustrierend, weil es mein Job eigentlich ist. Und hatte dann angefangen über ein Konzept nachzudenken, wenn jetzt übertrieben gesagt, ich es schon nicht mehr verstehe, der sich tagtäglich damit beschäftigt und das seit über 20 Jahren. Wie geht es dir dann eigentlich dem Zuschauer zu Hause? Und es ist eben nicht mehr, Jungs, ihr müsst rausgehen und Gras fressen, sondern es steckt mittlerweile viel, viel mehr dahinter und ich glaube einfach und so meine Erfahrung war auch dann in den Gesprächen mit Freunden, Bekannten, die eben auch Fußballkonsumenten sind, dass dieses Verständnis dessen, was auf dem Platz passiert, nicht mehr so da ist. Und das war so dieser Grundgedanke. Und dann gab es eben die Möglichkeit, ein neuer Player auf dem Markt mit Eurosport und dann hatten wir dann darüber gesprochen und auch das grundsätzliche Konzept, den Fußball stark in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen und jetzt mal übertrieben gesagt, lass uns den aktuellen Fußball doch mal wieder erklären. Und dazu brauchst du dann den perfekten Experten und dann hat Eurosport Gott sei Dank den Matthias dafür gewinnen können.
Hat es einen Grund, warum das bei einem neuen Player eher funktioniert als vielleicht bei bestehenden? Ich frage mich immer so ein bisschen, warum eigentlich die Fußball-Berichterstattung so aussieht, wie sie aussieht und meiner Einschätzung nach gab es eine Entwicklung mit der WM 2006, gerade mit der Rolle von Jürgen Klopp als Taktik-Experte beim ZDF. Auf einmal hat man über Ketten und Verschieben gesprochen. Da habe ich wahnsinnig viel gelernt und bin halt dann quasi da drangeblieben. Und ich hatte eigentlich den Eindruck, die Fußball-Berichterstattung hat sich da ein bisschen mehr auf die taktischen Hintergründe des Spiels fokussiert und irgendwo ist das verloren gegangen so ein bisschen. Jetzt reden wir doch wieder viel über, es hängt an Einzelpersonen oder eben an mentalen Dingen, die ja auch eine Rolle spielen, aber es wird, man kann ja viele mentale Dinge auch an taktischen Dingen erklären, an Sachen, die man beobachtet. Woher kommt, dass das dafür so wenig Platz ist in der Berichterstattung?
Erst einmal fand ich auch, dass Jürgen Glopp das hervorragend gemacht hat und er war vielleicht nicht Spieler auf allerhöchstem Niveau, aber er stand ja immer für Leidenschaft, für Kämpfen, für nicht aufgeben. Und gleichzeitig war der Verein über Wolfgang Frank natürlich auch ein Stück weit geprägt und raumorientiert. Die Ketten, die sie gerade genannt haben, spielten ja da auch eine Rolle und er konnte dort seinen Weg gehen mit natürlich Aufstiegen, auch Abstiegen, aber er hat sich dort wunderbar entwickeln können und neben dem Fachlichen hat er natürlich auch mit seiner Art und Weise die Leute begeistert, aber er war zu dem Zeitpunkt eben Spieler und Trainer. Also ich glaube, dass es sehr, sehr wichtig ist, wenn man auch versucht, verantwortungsvoll den Leuten etwas beizubringen, dass es vielleicht nicht allein ausreicht, nur Spieler gewesen zu sein. Nur Trainer gewesen zu sein, müsste ausreichen, weil er über die Fachkompetenz, natürlich in Pädagogik und Methodik und natürlich im Überbringen der Botschaften geschult sein muss, neben den Inhalten, die es gibt. Aber der Fußballer selber, der natürlich über viele Erfahrungen, der in Stadien gespielt hat, der auf dem grünen Rasen war, der das Riechen fühlen kann, ist aber wie ein Klavierspieler. Wenn du nicht in der Lage bist, einem anderen dann das Klavierspiel zu erklären, weil das ist ein Unterschied als selber zu spielen, so ist es vielleicht dann auch in der grundsätzlichen Denkweise, dass man Experten eigentlich erst einmal definieren sollte, was Voraussetzungen sind, um darüber zu reden. Das meine ich überhaupt nicht despektierlich, sondern mit der Voraussetzung, dass es möglicherweise alleine nicht reicht, ein sehr guter Spieler gewesen zu sein, wenn du dann über Management-Ebenen sprichst, über Trainer-Ebenen, über das Spiel im Allgemeinen und die Situation gar nicht nachvollziehen kannst, weil du sie nicht gelebt und erlebt hast. Das ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil und dementsprechend finde ich es schade, zum Beispiel Otmar Hitzfeld ist leider nicht mehr dabei. Ich habe ihn unglaublich gerne zugehört. Er hat so fantastisch analysiert. Seine menschlichen Fähigkeiten sind ja sowieso außergewöhnlich. Deshalb glaube ich, dass auch die Taktik im Allgemeinen nur ein Teil des Fußballs, aber nicht so einfach ist für die meisten.
Und es wird ja auch immer komplexer, finde ich. Wie sieht denn so die Sendungsvorbereitung bei Ihnen aus? Der Termin hat sich um eine Stunde verschoben. Da hole ich jetzt den Investigativreporter raus und sage, was ist in dieser Stunde passiert?
Nein, es ist so, wir haben auch unsere Vorbereitung etwas umgestellt. Am Anfang hatten wir uns komplett Donnerstags getroffen und saßen dann wirklich so sechs, sieben, acht Stunden hier.
Sie zu zweit?
Ja, drüben in so einem kleinen Glaskasten und haben dann dort über dieses Scouting-Feed, was großartig ist, also wer es nicht kennt, das ist diese Kameraeinstellungen, die gerade die Trainer benutzen in der Bundesliga, um sich auf den kommenden Gegner vorzubereiten. Da habe ich immer die 20 Feldspieler im Blick. Dann, wenn es Richtung Tor geht, sind es 21. Da kann ich dann genau die Verschiebungen, Räume und alles sehen. Und wenn man sich an dieses Bild gewöhnt, wird es dann irgendwann schwierig, sich ein Fußballspiel bei einer normalen Fernsehübertragung – Da fehlt was, ne? Ja, weil es ist immer wieder so – aber hier hinten, da ist was abgeschnitten, du siehst es nicht. Da wird man fast aggressiv dann davor, weil man dann den Grund gerade nicht versteht, warum ist das so gelaufen, wie es gelaufen ist. So, und das hatten wir dann am Anfang und da habe ich dann erstmal festgestellt, für mich auch ein komplett neuer Schritt, weil als Journalist bereitest du dich normalerweise nicht über ein Scouting-Field vor, sondern hast andere Herangehensweisen, dass ein Spiel nicht 90 Minuten dauert, sondern auch mal dreieinhalb Stunden, weil immer hier müssen wir nochmal zurück und hier nochmal angucken und da nochmal und hin und vor und das ist natürlich großartig. Für mich eine überragende Erfahrung, das waren dann so die Anfänge, nur das Ganze haben wir dann ein bisschen optimiert, dass wir jetzt jeder für sich, so war es jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Woche in der Vorbereitung, jeder für sich hat zu Hause die Mannschaften vorbereitet. Wir haben die Möglichkeit auch zu Hause auf dem Laptop uns das anzuschauen und dann kommen wir mit den Ergebnissen hierhin und besprechen dann eben die Szenen, die wir nehmen und das ist es letztlich, dass das die Szenen, die wir dann jetzt für die morgige Sendung ausgesucht haben, sind dort. Wir haben, was haben wir, ich glaube wieder elf oder zwölf Szenen, wo wir dann in der Sendung, wenn wir gut sind, schaffen wir sechs, vier ist der Normalfall und wir sagen immer, weil wir einmal das Spiel hatten, Köln gegen Freiburg, das war großartig für uns, wir haben Zeit geschenkt bekommen und Schneefall, was man vergessen hat.
Und das Field-Interview mit dem Platzbad war das beste.
Und das ist einfach dann für uns auch immer wieder, egal was passiert, ich sag immer, der Köcher ist voll, wir haben Feuer, weil es einfach auch Spaß macht und manchmal geht man dann raus und dann muss man auch in der Sendung entscheiden, na jetzt haben wir hier noch eigentlich vier Szenen, die wir hätten, wir können aber nur noch eine zeigen, welche nehmen wir und das ist jetzt so die Herangehensweise, wie wir es machen.
Und das heißt, es gibt dahinter jetzt kein großes Team, was die Szenen aufbereitet, sondern das liegt dann schon in ihren Händen und Köpfen, die komplette Vorbereitung?
Ja, weil wir der Meinung sind, innerhalb der Sendung dann auch die Details wissen zu müssen, also das letzte Spiel wissen muss. Natürlich verfolgst du dann auch davor, wer die Tore geschossen hat und was weiß ich. Also theoretisch könntest du jetzt, ist der 32. Spieltag, Mensch, was war am fünften Spieltag? Da hat auch Hoffenheim da. Du hast über dieses Scouting-Feed, über dieses Tool die Möglichkeit, eben immer, wie Jan beschrieben hat, aus der Kameraperspektive dir alles zurückzuholen. Und damit hast du einen Überblick und ein Gefühl für das Spiel und gleichzeitig in der Vorbereitung für die Sendung, dass du dann eben genau weißt, ah, das sind die Szenen, das können wir zeigen. Und es kann relativ wenig überraschen aus der Vergangenheit. Die Zukunft ist natürlich immer eine Trainerkonstellation, wo wir dann auch sehen, ja, es ist sicherlich so oder so möglich oder die Variante vom System her so oder so. Aber das ist dann auch nicht das Relevante für uns. Es ist auch das Schöne, um das dann wieder zu sehen, weil wir gucken die Spiele dann, obwohl wir in der Loge sind, nicht, also ich zumindest, nicht auf dem Spielfeld, sondern ich lasse das Scouting-Feed mit einem großen Monitor laufen, um da eben auch wieder den besseren Überblick zu haben. Und das macht uns zumindest, ob wir gut oder nicht gut sind, darum, ja, das müssen auch die Leute beurteilen, aber es macht uns zumindest sicher in unseren Handlungsweisen und in unserer Argumentation mit dieser Vorbereitung. Und das möchte ich keinen anderen machen lassen und ich glaube, wir haben uns da sehr gut dran gewöhnt.
Das ist das Entscheidende. Alles, was du selbst machst und selbst gesehen hast und selbst erlebst, kannst du dann auch anders benutzen in der Sendung. Wenn es vorbereitet wird und ich dann am Freitag vorgefertigte Clips bekomme und von jemandem eine Szene ausgesucht, ist es sicherlich gut. Nur, ich merke es ja auch, am Anfang habe ich keine Szene getroffen. Matthias hatte zehn Szenen und ich hatte auch zehn, aber das waren eben andere, die wir dann alle weggeschmissen haben und jetzt geht so langsam die Trefferquote ein bisschen höher. Aber ich werde doch nie im Leben, wie kann ich auch, dieses analytische Niveau, selbst wenn ich die Szene richtig rausgefunden habe, wie heute war dann eine Szene. Matthias hat sie auch, nur dann analysiert er sie und dann sehe ich noch mal plötzlich all das, was ich nicht gesehen habe. Ich habe gesehen, darüber kann man reden, aber ich kann es nicht so mit dem Inhalt füllen. Dafür brauchst du dann einfach einen Experten und da kommen wir auf das Thema, was Matthias eben gesagt hatte, wieder zurück. Was ist ein guter Experte? Ein Fußballer hat viel erlebt, ein Top-Fußballer, natürlich dann auf höchstem Niveau. Dann wäre es natürlich noch schön, wenn du nicht nur ein Top-Fußballer, sondern auch ein Top-Trainer bist, dir vielleicht auch mal was gewonnen an der deutschen Meisterschaft. Dann hast du das abgedeckt. Aber dann hast du noch andere journalistische Themen. Wäre natürlich schön, wenn du noch einen Vereinsfunktionär auch noch dort hättest. Bayern-Vorstand. Wenn du das Sahnehäubchen noch haben willst, dann sagst du, das ist noch was anderes. Ein guter Sportdirektor bei meinem DFB. Da hast du wirklich diese 360 Grad, die du über Matthias abdecken kannst. Das ist natürlich ein Geschenk.
Und wir haben drei Stühle eine Meinung. Ich sehe pro Bundesligaspieltag fünf bis sechs Spiele über 90 Minuten. Da fragen mich auch viele Hörerinnen und Hörer, warum ich da nicht mal delegiere oder was abgebe. Aber ich finde auch, wenn ich es nicht selber gesehen habe, kann ich nicht drüber urteilen. Und ich verlasse mich vor allem seitdem ich so viele Spiele über 90 Minuten sehe, weiß ich, wie wenig man sich auf Spielzusammenfassung verlassen kann.
Es ist dann nicht die Wahrnehmung und man trifft auch nicht die Seele des jeweiligen Spiels. Die Szenen, über die Jan gerade gesprochen hat, sie sind ein wichtiger Bestandteil des Spiels. Aber das Gefühl, das man selber gesehen haben muss, um genau zu wissen, in welchem Zusammenhang die Szenen stehen oder woher sie sich entwickelt haben. Wenn sie dann nicht das Spiel gesehen haben, können sie die Seele selber dieses Matches nicht fühlen. Die guten Zuhörer oder Zuschauer werden das auch komischerweise spüren. Das ist zumindest unsere Erfahrung und zumindest zu einem gewissen Teil. Natürlich gibt es auch ein Publikum, die sich unterhalten wollen und wie auch immer. Ich hoffe, dass das auch einigermaßen gelingt. Aber es geht schon sehr, es zu fühlen und im Detail zu erklären.
Ist auch dort ein Ansatz? Die Analysemaschine, die wir haben, könnte jetzt unter dem Motto Villa Kunterbunt viel mehr. Hier könnte noch etwas blinken und da könnte noch etwas aufploppen oder sonst irgendwas. Die Erfahrung zeigt einfach, dass es häufig ablenkt und deshalb finde ich es immer ganz gut, keine Bild-Text-Schere, das heißt also, ich rede zu dem, was ich einzeichne. Wenn schon wieder irgendwo was blinkt oder bin ich gedanklich vielleicht schon den Schritt weiter, aber mit der Sprache noch gar nicht da. Und deshalb auch dort ist weniger manchmal mehr und es ist dann begleitend. Also dann passt es wirklich, guck dir hier die Viererkette an und in dem Moment siehst du dann eben den Strich und dann ist auch das Auge dann dort. Also das ist schon…
Das ist didaktisch.
Ja, auch für die Damen und Herren, die uns die Maschine damals vorgestellt hatten, das war großartig. Ich dachte, das ist hier ein Flipper und das blinkt und… Das ist toll, was das Ding denn kann, nur ich finde, wenn Matthias es selbst einzeichnet, hat das nochmal eine andere A-Wertigkeit und du bist eben parallel mit dem, was du zeichnest, auch beim Wort.
Jetzt stelle ich mir dann aber die Frage, das haben sie auch gerade so ein bisschen anklingen lassen, dass manchmal die Szenen, die sie rausgesucht haben, nicht gematcht haben mit ihren Szenen und dass es jetzt eine Übereinstimmung gäbe. Aber gibt es denn eigentlich immer den einen korrekten taktischen Blick? Da bin ich mir nämlich manchmal gar nicht so sicher. Also in den Grundfesten sollte man, wenn man taktisch auf ein Spiel guckt, schon bei demselben Ding rauskommen. Also was es Systeme angeht, was bestimmte so gruppentaktische Dynamiken angeht. Aber bei so Detailfragen, finde ich, fehlt manchmal der genauere Blick. Also ein Beispiel zum Beispiel, es gab zwei Partien von Sebastian Rudy. Eine war in Mainz, das zweite ist mir gerade der Gegner entfallen. Da hat er sich nie aus dem Deckungsschatten seines Gegenspielers rausbewegt. Und zwar kein einziges Mal. Und im ersten Moment, die ersten 20 Minuten, dachte ich, was macht er denn da? Was ist denn da los? Und dann kam mir aber so der Gedanke, vielleicht ist seine Aufgabe, die Korridore zu den achtern Freizeiten. Weil mir ist dann irgendwann aufgefallen, dass er auch relativ statisch blieb. Und dann war halt der eine Gegenspieler geblockt. Aber um das jetzt rauszufinden, ob das seine Aufgabe war – ich meine, Sie könnten es, Herr Sammer, ich nicht – müsste ich ja eigentlich mal anrufen, den Telefonhörer heben und dann bei irgendem verantwortlich nachfragen. Und eigentlich wäre ja dieses Wissen nötig, um das richtig zu bewerten.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher. Es obliegt, glaube ich, nicht unsere Aufgabe, immer die Perfektion herzustellen, sondern aufzuzeigen, was uns aufgefallen ist, auch machbar, praktikabel, dass man folgen kann als Fernsehzuschauer, um zu sehen, ah, okay, das ist eine gewisse Richtung, wie Sie gerade gesagt haben. Systeme ist ja nur das eine, aber die Idee, wie wird sie organisiert, was ist dabei? Ah, und Sebastian Rudy ist jetzt für uns auffällig immer wieder in einer Situation des Spiels, Aufbauspiel, etc. immer unter gewissen Voraussetzungen auf einer wiedererkennbaren Position geblieben. Das war so, aber ich finde, es ist gar nicht so entscheidend, um zu sagen, das ist richtig oder das ist falsch, sondern wie sie gerade auch sagen, die Konsequenz daraus, was ich da gesehen habe, war, aber dadurch war es für die Achte leichter, weil er dann Räume nicht zugestellt hat. Jetzt muss man sehen, dass es nicht zu kompliziert wird. A hat er das unter diesen Gesichtspunkten klug gemacht, aber ich finde, es ist gar nicht so entscheidend. War das jetzt hundertprozentig die Strategie? Wichtig ist, zu sagen, das haben wir gesehen und das ist uns aufgefallen. Das ist so gemacht worden, hätte man aber theoretisch auch anders machen können. Das ist zumindest unsere Erfahrung, dass das Erkennen in der Verhältnismäßigkeit des Warums nur bedingt entscheidend ist, sondern es aufzuzeigen, um zu sagen, das war so, das sah da und da gut aus. Und selbst wenn es die Vorgabe war, dann zu sagen, aber ich glaube, es war trotzdem anders möglich und besser, weil – und dann wieder aufgezeigt – ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant, weil das Spiel selber und seine Gänse doch viele Geheimnisse bürgt. Und auch wenn wir vielleicht das ein oder andere Lob bekommen, sehen wir doch ganz vieles nicht.
Zumal, dass du ja auch immer sagst, es geht gar nicht darum, die Idee des Trainers zu kritisieren, die wird einfach akzeptiert, so wie sie ist. Und um dieses Beispiel aufzunehmen, ich glaube auch, wenn man jetzt einen Guardiola und einen Klopp nimmt, dass ein Guardiola zu einer Situation was sagen würde, wie kannst du nur? Wie können die nur so stehen? Und Klopp sagt, das ist genau das, was ich will und umgekehrt genauso. Weil einfach zwei Top-Trainer zwei unterschiedliche Philosophien von Fußball haben und dementsprechend gibt es nicht diese eine richtige Taktik. Deshalb die eine Idee, das ist deine, die ist so und die verfolgst du und am Ende zeigt sich eben, welche dann erfolgreicher ist. Wobei es ja nicht nur die Taktik ist, da kommt die Nöde der Klasse noch mit dazu und was weiß ich nicht noch alles.
Genau, das finde ich aber auch noch einen interessanten Punkt. Was mache ich denn mit Faktoren wie Form, mentale Frische, also gerade wenn wir in den Bereich des Kopfes gehen, dann wird es ja auch so ein bisschen esoterisch fast schon. Wir vermuten jetzt einfach mal, eventuell hat der Spieler diesen Geisteszustand gerade gehabt. Und das finde ich sehr schwierig, das in eine journalistische Betrachtungsweise mit reinzuziehen, weil es spielt definitiv eine Rolle, aber man neigt dazu überbewerten. Zum Teil geht es einem vielleicht auch gar nichts an, wenn man über Drucksituationen spricht, vielleicht auch mal andere Dinge, die einen Spieler beschäftigen. Und da frage ich mich, wie soll das in der Sportberichterstattung stattfinden? Weil das sind ja auch Faktoren, die wichtig sind für ein Spiel.
Fußball ist komplex und Taktik ist ein Bestandteil von mehreren. Es gibt fünf Leistungsvoraussetzungen. Das ist die Konstitution. Dann gibt es die Konjunktion und von da ins Detail zu gehen. Technik. Dann kommen wir zu Taktik und persönlichkeitsrelevante Themen, wie sie gerade genannt haben. Mentales. In welcher Verfassung ist er? Wie waren die letzten Spiele? Zusammenhang zwischen Körper und Geist ist den Menschen insgesamt bekannt. Deshalb ist auch der taktische Ansatz der Analyse immer nur ein Bestandteil, der gut aufzuzeigen ist, wenn du gewisse Tools hast, die die Menschen zu Hause nachvollziehen können. Genauso wenig, wie wir in den Kopf des Spielers in dem Moment reinschauen können und spekulativ meinen, dass er so ist, dass er am Boden ist oder dass er arrogant ist. Die Mentalität ist nicht in Ordnung. Die Bayern hätten dagegen Real Madrid. Thomas Müller hat es gesagt, diese Gier zu zeigen. Jetzt denken die Leute, das gibt es doch nicht. Da muss man doch Gier zeigen. Es geht ja immer um winzige Prozentpunkte, die auf dem Niveau den Unterschied ausmachen können. Deshalb ist die Spielanalyse in der Regel immer unter taktischen Gesichtspunkten zu sehen. Das Spiel selber aber ganz andere Schwerpunkte hat, warum Ergebnisse zustande kommen, Leistungen und auch manchmal Nichtleistungen dann zu sehen sind.
Wenn man über die individuelle Klasse spricht, muss man das dann einordnen. Meins, die gerade in einer speziellen Situation sind. Ich laufe anders auf, da habe ich diesen Druck. Der Fuß wird ein bisschen wackelig. Den Pass spielt er in der jetzigen Situation sicherlich anders als wenn die schon 40 Punkte auf dem Konto hätten. Dann laufe ich natürlich ganz anders auf. Da muss man mit ansprechen. Trotzdem kann man die rein taktische Situation analysieren und dann eben den Zusatz sagen, wer weiß, ob er den anders gespielt hätte. Nur ist hypothetisch, er ist jetzt in der Situation.
Also ist taktisch so ein bisschen das Wert Neutralste sprechen über den Fußball. So gewinne ich jetzt gerade den Eindruck. Und trotzdem muss man ja auch manchmal – oder nein, man muss nicht kritisieren – aber manchmal ist für jeden zu sehen, es passieren Fehler. Heutzutage im deutschen Fußball ist es ja vor allem so, er ist der Fehler, dann die Torchance. Wenn beide Mannschaften keinen Fehler machen, dann gibt es nur bei drei Mannschaften vielleicht eine Liga, dann eine Torchance, weil die mit dem Ball können. Wie macht man das denn, über Spieler, über Fehler zu sprechen, wohl wissend, dass die unter einem enormen Druck stehen, dass es nicht gerecht ist auch immer von – wir haben ja auch immer die ganz tolle Position, dass wir außen stehen und sowieso im Nachhinein immer alles besser wissen könnten. Wie findet man da den richtigen Mittelweg zwischen Kritik üben oder zumindest auf Fehler hinweisen und trotzdem aber den Spieler Mensch sein zu lassen, zu dem Fehler dazugehören?
Ich glaube, die Handlung versuchen zu erklären und unter verschiedensten Voraussetzungen ist es ein Laufduell, ist es eine Eins-gegen-eins-Situation im Zweikampf, dann immer wieder nicht das zu reduzieren, was man im deutschen Fußball gerne gemacht hat. Einstellung Katastrophe, das ist überhaupt nichts, das ist zu einfach. Ich glaube, dass es einfach sehr wichtig ist, Handlungsweisen selber zu fühlen, wenn man in Situationen vielleicht selber sich auch mal befunden hat. Dann auch versucht, aufgrund der Abläufe in einer Situation zu erklären, dass es eben nicht um die Person im dem Moment geht, sondern um Handlungsweisen, die im dem Moment falsch angewendet wurden. Und das ist eigentlich so in dem knappen Jahr, was wir jetzt gemacht haben, auch aus der Liga, ist ja ein schmaler Grad, dann auch wieder Rückmeldungen zu bekommen. Eigentlich auch dahingehend für uns etwas Besonderes, das möchte ich schon sagen, dass man nicht das Gefühl hatte, ja, man kriegt ja wöchentlich einen Anruf, um zu sagen, Mensch, da hättest du den aber auch mal ein bisschen schonen können, oder wie auch immer, sondern dass es eigentlich darum gar nicht ging, weil man HSV einmal mit dem Platz war, aber grundsätzlich gar nicht darum ging, anzurufen, um nachzusagen, das war nicht korrekt, sondern dass es eigentlich in der Regel immer darum ging, um zu sagen, es ist überhaupt kein Thema gewesen, das auch kritisch erklärt wurde und nicht populistisch herausposant.
Denn es geht ja nicht gegen die Person, gegen den Menschen, sondern es geht um die Leistung, um die Position, die er vielleicht gerade auf dem Spielfeld eingenommen hat, die falsch ist, wenn er einfach fünf Meter vorne stehen würde, wie auch immer. Und da ist der Sport ja ehrlich und das kann man kritisieren und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen unser Ansatz. Warum sieht das Studio so ein bisschen aus wie eine Kabine? Weil diese Analyse – so wie es Matthias ja auch macht – Video-Studium seit Jahren in der Bundesliga schon völlig normal. Solche Sachen sind die Spieler ja auch gewohnt, weil der Trainer oder der Analyst oder wer auch immer mit denen die Szenen ja auch so durchgeht und vor der Mannschaft wird es ja auch angesprochen. Guck mal hier, wie stehst du dort? Walsches Positionsspiel oder die Abwehr hinten. Ihr steht viel zu tief oder wie auch immer, geht ein bisschen raus, dann stehen die abseits. Solange es sportlich bleibt und das ist eben unser Ansatz und nicht gegen die Person geht, auch wenn natürlich sieht mal ein Spieler schlecht aus. Ja, das ist nur mal so in dem Spiel. Aber es geht nicht darum, den Spieler niederzumachen, sondern die Situation darzustellen und zu erklären.
Sie haben ja auch, Herr Henkel, einen engen Bezug zum italienischen Fußball. Kennt man sie ja auch noch fließend aus dem italienischen ins deutsche und wieder ins italienische bei Sky-Übertragungen. Wie ist denn die italienische Fußballberichterstattung dem Klischee nach folgend – und ich weiß es aber nicht – hätte ich gesagt, die haben auch einen eher taktischeren Blick auf den Fußball.
Die italienische Berichterstattung ist sexy und taktisch.
Sexy taktisch oder sexy untaktisch?
Die zeigen sehr viel Haut dort auch. Ein Italiener, wenn der Fußball guckt, braucht der eine hübsche Frau im Minirock daneben. Ist so im italienischen Fernsehen. Das gehört mit dazu, die wachsen so auf. Das sind dort auch angesehene und völlig normale Jobs. Die Kameras kommen aus der Werbung mit den langen Beinen wieder raus und fahren ins Décolleté zu, wenn es dann wieder in die Werbung reingeht. Das ist das eine. Aber das andere, das habe ich dort unten auch immer wieder genossen in all den Jahren, das taktische Niveau des italienischen Fußballfans ist um ein Vielfaches höher, als es in Deutschland der Fall ist. Da habe ich auch ein paar Beispiele. Ich kann mich noch an die WM USA, das war 94, erinnern. Da ging es darum, der alte Badjo, Roberto Badjo, oder der Junge Del Piero. Und Diskussion in der Bar. Was heißt es taktisch für die Mannschaft? Was verändert sich durch den unterschiedlichen Spieltypus, der eine so, der andere so? Das war so das allererste Mal, wo ich so mit großen Augen in einer ganz normalen Bar daneben stand und merkte, okay, über sowas reden die Leute. Oder selbst im Fernsehen, und das war ganz heftig bei dem Europa League Spiel AC Florenz gegen Borussia Mönchengladbach, das war gar nicht so lange her, anderthalb Jahre ungefähr. Da hatten nämlich die Kollegen von Scarra Italia geschaltet in deren Studio und da ging es drum, was ändert sich? Die Frage war, bei Borussia Mönchengladbach, ob Raphael oder Stindl hinter dem Stoßstürmer spielen. Das ist eine Frage im italienischen Fernsehen zum Gegner. Und wenn ich jetzt das mal hier ins deutsche Fernsehen projizieren würde, jetzt nicht das Spiel Bayern gegen Real Madrid nehmen, sondern Borussia Mönchengladbach gegen den AC Florenz. Eine Frage eines deutschen Journalisten an einen italienischen Journalisten, was es heißt in Florenz, wenn, Chiesa über außen oder wer auch immer. Das Niveau haben wir gar nicht, weil wir nicht so aufgewachsen sind in Deutschland. Die Menschen, Trapp Artoni damals, als er bei den Bayern war, der sagte mir, das ist hier großartig für mich. Beste Konferenz. Die fragen mich, was hat der Effenberg heute Nacht gemacht? Wie lange war der Basler unterwegs? Aber glaubst du, da kommt einer auf mich zu und fragt mich, hör mal Trapp, in der 64. Minute hast du die Auswechslung vorgenommen. Warum denn das? Du hättest doch auch den bringen können. Und dann hättest du auf 4-4-2 mit Raute, flacher 6 oder was weiß ich, umstellen können und dadurch hättest du die und die Räume. Da hat er gesagt, die Fragen werden mir gar nicht gestellt. Und das ist wirklich ein Riesenunterschied, wie ich auch aufwachse in einem Land als Fußballfan, was mir das Fernsehen schon mal vorgibt. Und dadurch bin ich natürlich auch ein bisschen geprägt.
Klar, aber hat natürlich auch was mit der Historie zu tun. Die Deutschen haben sehr lange mannorientiert gespielt, im klassischen 3-5-2 mit Libero. Und die allgemeine Denkweise war immer, wenn die marschieren, wenn sie noch ein paar gute Spieler haben, und einen Mittelstürmer oder einen guten Libero. Das ist immer sehr persönlich auch gewesen, um ganz am Ende zu sagen, der hat den Zweikampf gewonnen oder verloren. Dieses strategische, taktische, speziell in Italien, aber auch eher ein Stück weit gegen den Ball. Aufgrund der Tatsache, dass natürlich die Italiener mit einem guten Verteidigungsstil, das Catenaccio, der im Allgemeinen bekannt ist, aus einer guten, raumorientierten Spielweise Positionen zu besetzen. Das hat etwas mit Geschichte und Historie zu tun. Das war in Deutschland lange Zeit nicht ausgeprägt. Und ich glaube nach wie vor, dass auch gewisse Generationen in Italien schon von klein auf damit konfrontiert wurden, das natürlich auch so wahrzunehmen und darüber zu reden und damit einen eigenen Stil zu kreieren. Das gibt es in Deutschland noch nicht so lange. Die jüngeren Generationen jetzt, aber die Details natürlich noch nicht so intus, haben gegenüber den älteren, natürlich manchmal wie mit jüngeren oder älteren Trainern, in Deutschland auch die Thematik gibt, um zu sagen, das ist die Entwicklung, das ist moderne, das ist das Heute und die ältere Generation oftmals noch in ihrer Entwicklung mit dem, was wir gerade gesagt haben, konfrontiert worden. Und diese Gesichtspunkte, gar keine so große Rolle geschehen, wie wir sie gespielt haben, sondern der ist nicht fit, der kann nicht genug laufen, langsam ist er auch gewonnen und Zweikämpfer verliert er auch. Das war die Diskussion, ein bisschen übertrieben gesagt, im deutschen Fußball.
Ja, der Zweikämpfer ist das beste Beispiel. Nur wir Deutschen schauen auf Zweikampfquoten. Da sagen die im Grunde fast gar nichts.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass es eben grundsätzlich dem italienischen Fußball zwischendurch geschadet hat. Ja, deutlich. Zu sehr auf das Taktische und gegen den Ball und individualisierte Ausbildung hat dann weniger eine Rolle gespielt. Und auch das Kreative, das Freiheitliche zu lassen, das ist natürlich auch diskutabel. Und deshalb hat der italienische Fußball – für mich hat er die Talsohle jetzt schon länger durchschritten, aber zwischendurch auch große Probleme. Und ich glaube, dass die A, Identität, und B, immer die Komplexität des Spiels in seiner Anwendung natürlich großartig ist und das Erfolgreiche auch bringen wird. Oder wollte mir jemand sagen, dass Real Madrid in München nicht gespielt hat wie die schlimmsten deutschen Spiele in ihrer Vergangenheit, aber sie haben sie halt gewonnen und keiner konnte es erklären.
Na gut, Sie meinen jetzt das Spiel gestern, aber da gab es ja auch zum Beispiel ein taktisches Mittel, dass der lange Ball immer zwischen die Innenverteidiger bzw. Ronaldo hat sich oft neben Hummels, glaube ich, fallen lassen und ist einmal aus dem Abseits rausgekommen, da war es abseits, das zweite Mal war es sehr knapp und beides Mal war es aber so, dass er genau in der Schnittstelle stand.
Aber Sie haben nicht geschafft, das, was Sie wollten, Ballbesitzfußball zu spielen. Über Toni Groß, über Luca Motric und Casemiro erstmal im Zentrum und Ronaldo als den einen gegen zwei Innenverteidiger auf die Seiten zu stellen, würde ja gleichzeitig bedeuten, dass ich zwei Spiele des Gegners eliminiert habe im Zentrum und ich habe im mittleren Bereich des Spiels eigentlich eine zweifache Überzahl-Situation, aber es nicht gelungen. Die Theorie war grandios, aber Sie dann, Toni Groß nach dem Spiel, Ramos ein bisschen anders, haben eindeutig bemängelt zu wenig Ballbesitzzeiten, zu wenig Ballsicherheit, zu viele Bälle schnell verloren und das haben Sie kritisiert und gleichzeitig aber leider, ich habe es auch nur im Fernsehen gesehen, konntest du dann Zusammenhänge über Scouting-Feed leider nicht erkennen, weil wir das nicht hatten, wo du gesagt hast, aber Real, oh, immer früh gestört. Also anders als vielleicht noch im letzten Jahr, wo Real plötzlich tief verteidigt hat, wo du gesagt hast, oh, die Abläufe stimmen, aber es war eigentlich eher ein Abwehrpressing, vielleicht im Übergang zum Mittelfeld, aber Sie haben jetzt teilweise Angriffspressing gespielt. Also das war sicherlich ein überraschendes taktisches Merkmal, aber geprägt von Löchern, die sie auch hatten. Mama mia! Und dass Bayern das nicht ausgenutzt hat, war zumindest gestern schade, aber es war ja erst das erste Spiel.
Als Sie jetzt vorhin über den italienischen Fußball gesprochen haben und dass man da viel gegen den Ball gespielt hat und dass man da ein bisschen die Kreativität und die Individualförderung vergessen hat, hatte ich kurz den Eindruck, reden wir jetzt über Italien Ende der 90er oder reden wir über Deutschland im Jahr 2018?
Was ich immer gut finde, Tendenzen und das können wir Deutschen sehr, sehr gut, manchmal auch ein bisschen übertrieben, manchmal auch ein bisschen falsch, schon frühzeitig zu benennen. Also wir sind dann manchmal auch nicht in der Lage, dann mehr zu sehen, was wir eigentlich gut machen, sondern wir haben so diese selbstzerstörerische Argumentation und Verhaltensweise, dass dann alles irgendwie schwierig ist und schlecht ist und dass es das nicht mehr gibt und in der Ausbildung. So und dann gucke ich und denke, Leroy Sané spielt mit roundabout 20 in einem der besten Clubs der Welt. Würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein Sechser ist, der nur hacken kann. Das ist ein Individualist. Julian Brand in Leverkusen, Kai Havertz und wir können viele nennen. Joshua Kimmich ist wieder ein ganz anderer Typ, aber schon ein eigener Typ. Deshalb müssen wir auch ein bisschen vorsichtig sein in der Bewertung grundsätzlich. Das ist die Spitze. Wir brauchen grundsätzlich die Herangehensweise, die wir auch unter persönlichkeitsrelevanten Themen oftmals falsch angegangen sind, zu sagen, die Mannschaft steht im Mittelpunkt. Das stimmt nicht. Aus den Individuen wird eine Mannschaft. Und je komplexer, aber gleichzeitig vom Geist her geschulte Individuen anerkennen, auch Reparier oder Robben, irgendwann gemerkt haben, wir können so sein, wie wir sind, aber ohne die Mannschaft haben wir keine Chance. Die muss nicht sein wie Martinez oder Boateng oder Neuer und Schweinsteiger und Müller. Die Mannschaft kommt am Ende. Zuerst kommt mal die persönliche Entwicklung und Qualität. Und die gilt es sicherlich mehr in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen als das, was wir aktuell in der Bundesliga erleben, um zu sagen, gegen den Ball, enge Abstände und plötzlich kommt der Ball und wir gegen Traktor Puse-Muckel, sag ich zuletzt immer, haben wir dann auch keine Mittel, um zu sagen, wir können die eigentlich gar nicht mehr ausspielen, weil natürlich auch in der Bundesliga kommt ein Underdog zu einem vermeintlichen Favoriten noch auswärts. Da hat der Underdog sich schon immer hinten reingestellt oder versucht zu verteidigen, nur die andere Mannschaft hat versucht anzugreifen. Nur im Moment erkennen wir in der Bundesliga, dass eigentlich beide versuchen dann zu verteidigen. Und das ist keine optimale Entwicklung.
Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, wie kann sich der Fußball in der Bundesliga daraus entwickeln? Weil das hat ja auch einen Grund, dass man diesen Fehler vermeidenden Fußball spielt. Zum einen, weil in der Bundesliga schon immer eine Liga war, zumindest jetzt in den 2000ern, wo Fehler sehr gut bestraft wurden. Also in dem Moment, wo das Umschaltspiel in Deutschland ankam, 2010 folgende, würde ich mal sagen, Jürgen Klopp, wichtige Rolle gespielt. Slomka, Hannover 96 mit der 10-Sekunden-Regel, das kannten die Spanier schon ganz lange. In Deutschland war das eine große Neuigkeit. Ab da war es sehr, sehr teuer, häufig im Spielaufbau einen Fehler zu machen. Deswegen denken jetzt die Mannschaften aus dieser Fehlervermeidung heraus und gleichzeitig haben wir eine Situation, wo wir auch eine irre Rotation auf den Trainerbänken haben. Also sprich, die Trainer haben ja auch gar nicht mehr die Zeit, das aufzubauen, denn das Ballbesitzspiel ist ja das viel, viel anspruchsvollere als das Spiel gegen den Ball. Und ich frage mich, wie in dieser Gesamtkonstellation, die wir gerade haben, mit dem das Fußball auch so ein bisschen überhöht wird, also dass eine Niederlage am Wochenende auch wirklich ist, als wäre jetzt hier gerade die Welt untergegangen und man gar nicht so sehr mehr auf das Wie der Niederlage gucken kann, sondern es wirklich nur noch Ergebnisse zählen und gleichzeitig viele Trainer natürlich von Erfolg zu Erfolg denken müssen, denn Fußball wird ja erstmal in Siegen und in Niederlagen und Unentschieden gemessen. Wie soll sich das langfristig entwickeln? Ich bin da so ein bisschen aufgeschmissen fast.
Ich glaube, dass wir uns in Prozessen befinden. Wir haben gerade vorher über die Taktik gesprochen, die natürlich jetzt einen Mittelpunkt einnimmt, auch in der Trainerausbildung, der vielleicht etwas überhitzt ist und die neue Generation der Trainer sich damit natürlich so extrem auseinandersetzt und sich so damit identifiziert, dass sie da nicht angreifbar werden wollen. Die etwas ältere Generation sagt, Taktik ist nicht unwichtig, weiß ich schon, aber es gibt gewisse andere Themen, wie die Persönlichkeit einer Mannschaft und so auch die gewisse Flexibilität, diese sogenannte Old School, wo natürlich erkennbar ist, ob ich da jetzt mal einen taktischen Fehler mache oder nicht, das spielt etwas weniger eine Rolle. Die verzeihen sich das auch selber ein bisschen mehr als die jüngere Generation. Und diese Mischung ist im Moment natürlich mit der gesamten Entwicklung nicht stabil. Es fehlt für meine Begriffe auch so das stabile Fundament. Wenn jetzt Hup Hynkes nicht gewesen wäre, hättest du noch Dieter Hecking. Ralf Hasenhüttl muss sich nach zu jung zählen innerhalb der Liga und seiner Entwicklung. Der ist noch nicht 20 Jahre in der ersten Fußballbundesliga wie vielleicht andere oder zehn. Deshalb muss man das auch. Dann gibt es Dieter Hecking und dann wird es schon langsam eng. Bruno Labbadia ist jetzt eine Zeit lang dabei geblieben. Und Volker Finke, der natürlich – nicht Volker Finke – streicht. Aber diese Situation in Freiburg, die wieder sich etwas eigen darstellt. Wir haben insgesamt gerade eine Mischung, die sich nicht optimal darstellt. Und natürlich die Identität, Erfolg zu benennen, hat Herangehensweisen. Und sie haben gerade gesagt, die Mechanismen, Trainer zu bewerten aufgrund des nackten Ergebnisses, hat natürlich auch ein Sportdirektorenproblem. Wie viele Sportdirektoren waren gleichzeitig Trainer in Deutschland, um überhaupt einen Trainer bewerten zu können? Also wir haben mehrere Fehler im System, sodass – was haben alle gemacht? Wenn du in den Wald gegangen bist, dunkel, Angst, bist du langsam gegangen. Hoffentlich hört mich keiner oder sieht mich keiner. Und was macht die Fußball-Bundesliga? Sie glaubt, im Verteidigen liegt die Zukunft und die Fehlervermeidung. Das stimmt aber nicht. Weil wir noch nicht mal in der Bundesliga gut verteidigen. Also da gibt es so viele wirklich Stellungsfehler. Die Linien werden nicht gehalten. Sechzehner Verhalten nach Flanken des Gegners. Also das machen wir auch nicht gut. Und das, was ich eigentlich sagen will, ist, wir müssen uns an den Besten orientieren. Und die Besten wollen die Kugel. Und die Besten, die die Kugel meistens haben, neben der individuellen Qualität, die sind überall erfolgreich. Die Definitionen und die Gedankengänge, die auch jüngere Trainer aktuell haben, sind aufgrund fehlender Erfahrungswerte inhaltlich falsch. Jetzt kommen Sie hier zu mir. Aber Schalke 04. Schalke 04 kann nur funktionieren so, dass ich großen Respekt habe, weil die Bundesliga so schlecht ist. Wenn die Bundesliga besser wäre, wäre Schalke roundabout 8 bis 10.
Ja, und wenn man sowas aber sagt, dann wird einem vorgeworfen populistisch zu sein. Also ich habe da erhitze Debatten mit Schalke-Fans geführt, weil das natürlich auch im Rasenfunk viel diskutiert wurde. Sollte Schalke da stehen, wo es steht? Und die eine Argumentationslinie ist natürlich, wenn die Ergebnisse stimmen, dann ist es so. Aber die andere Frage ist, warum steht man mit so einem Fußball auf Tabellenplatz?
Weil die anderen zu schlecht sind, weil die anderen auch nur verteidigen, außer Bayern München, der ein oder andere noch aber eine eigene Identitäts- und Sinnkrise gerade hat und sich selber nicht findet. Und deshalb ist es nicht populistisch, weil es ist – wer jetzt gut zugehört hat – gar kein Vorwurf an Schalke. Es ist ein Vorwurf an den deutschen Fußball. Und letztendlich die Grundkonstellation und die Stabilität – Tedesco, wir haben oft mit ihm zu tun, auch in den Spielen – ich habe großen Respekt als junger Trainer, diesen verrückten Verein so stabilisiert, die Emotionen kanalisiert zu haben. Das ist eine außergewöhnliche Leistung. Ich habe nur über die Art und Weise des Spiels gesprochen. Das würde in einer aktuell besseren Liga nicht ausreichen können, um die Champions League zu erreichen. Nur das. Und es ist nicht populistisch, sondern es ist die Art und Weise des Verteidigens, um gleichzeitig in eigenem Ballbesitz, in der eigenen Kreation, wenn du relativ wenig Raum hast, doch zu wenig Qualität und Ideen hast. Und das würde auf Top-Niveau nicht funktionieren können.
Nur das. Ich glaube, dass wir im Moment in der Phase sind, Problem ist erkannt, es wird diskutiert und wir sind jetzt so an dem Schritt, wo die ersten angefangen haben zu sagen, ja, es geht nur, Lösungen mit dem Ball zu finden. Jogi Löw war ja auch bei uns in der Sendung, als wir in Freiburg waren, das war ihm auch noch mal ein Anliegen, das ganz klar zu thematisieren. Wenn ich mir den europäischen Fußball anschaue, du hast mal das Beispiel gebracht, Real Madrid gegen Celta Vigo. Ist gar nicht interessant, wie spielt Real Madrid, sondern wie spielt Celta Vigo Fußball? Lösungen mit dem Ball, das ist das Entscheidende. Und europäisch kriegen wir die Quittung, die Mannschaften, die den Bundesliga-Fußball-Fehlervermeidung und gegen den Ball, die werden alle nicht weit kommen, weil auf dem Niveau dann eben anderes gefragt ist. Und ich glaube, dass man dadurch fast gezwungen wird, den Stil etwas zu ändern, wieder etwas weiter weg von gegen den Ball und dann hin Lösungen mit dem Ball zu finden.
Die grundsätzliche Überlegung, als Basis verteidigen zu können, wird immer Bestandteil des Spiels sein.
Muss ja.
Immer Bestandteil des Spiels sein, also nicht, dass man das falsch versteht. Jetzt ist man aber zum Beispiel Mannschaften, die gegen den Abstieg spielen, unter normalen Umständen, ein bisschen oberflächig jetzt, die werden eher verteidigen und über Umschaltspiegel, Kontersituationen, große Räume versuchen dann über Laufverhalten und Schnelligkeit und Geschwindigkeit den Gegner ins Mark zu treffen. Das gab es schon immer und das wird auch immer so bleiben. Nur die grundsätzliche Ausgewogenheit der Mannschaften, die im Mittelfeld in der Bundesliga sind oder aber auch Spitzenmannschaften im eigentlichen Sinne, wie wir sie gerade benannt haben, sind dann nicht in der Lage, vermeintlich etwas schlechtere Mannschaften auszuspielen. Und das ist ein großes Problem. Unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass wir es gerade nicht taktisch definieren, müsste man ja eigentlich den Begriff des Rumpelns wieder ein bisschen rausholen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen jetzt a. im populistischen Sinne allgemein gehalten, aber b. ist es leider die Wahrheit. Und diesen Unterschied müssen wir wieder herstellen, dass wir hinter Bayern München das, was auf der einen Seite die Bundesliga noch interessant macht, wo angeblich jeder jeden schlagen kann – ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Kriterium ist – dass es im Prinzip eine gesunde Entwicklung, die Mischungen haben muss, um zu sagen, also die, die und die spielen immer um die Champions League. Mal schaffen sie es, mal fallen sie raus. Was ist denn zuletzt passiert? Die, die, die, die und die sind normal sicher im Mittelfeld aufgrund von Qualität, Budget und Geld. Die, die, die und die spielen sicher gegen den Abstieg. Das ist irgendwo normalerweise vermeintlich lesbar. Und wenn man sich das bei uns anguckt, was in den letzten Tests total verschoben, total verschwommen. Die Stabilität des oberen Bereiches gibt es überhaupt nicht. Im mittleren Bereich wird dann so, oh, wenn wir das erreichen, ist schon gut genug. Und die hinten, ja, die, die, die kämpfen auf der einen Seite ums Überleben, aber müssen erst mal sehen, da fliegen reitenweise die Träne raus, haben gar keine Stabilität. Von der Kompetenz in manchen Vereinen will ich gar nicht reden. Und deshalb glaube ich, dass wir schon ein paar inhaltliche Punkte im Detail besprechen müssen, was Jogi eben auch gesagt hat. Und klar spielen ein paar Spieler im Ausland, aber er hat eine ganz andere Idee vom Fußball und versucht, sie besser zu organisieren. Die meisten versuchen erst, ein System in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen und überlegen dann, wie die Organisation des Spiels und die Idee aussehen können. Das ist ein falscher Ansatz.
Welche Rolle spielt es denn da, wie sich der Fußball wirtschaftlich entwickelt hat? Meine These dazu ist so ein bisschen, dass wir gerade einen Brain Drain erleben Richtung Premier League. Und zwar nicht nur auf den Trainerposten – das ist so die plakativste Position – sondern auch so und nicht nur auf Top-Positionen, dass eben ein Leroy Sané zum Beispiel eben zu Manchester City wechselt und nicht innerhalb der Bundesliga bleibt, sondern auch im Mittelbau, würde ich ihn jetzt mal nennen. Also sowohl Spieler, die technisch gut veranlagt sind, die für eine sehr erkleckliche Summe rüberwechseln, aber auch viel rund um den Staff von Fußball-Bundesligisten, also Ernährungsberater wechseln in die Premier League, Physiotherapeuten und so weiter.
Das ist ja einfach zu erklären.
Nein.
Finde ich schon.
Grundlage. Also ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, dass Bebquart-Jolan Engländer war, außer ich habe was falsches mitbekommen.
Es geht darum, dass die meisten…
Die besten Trainer, die es auf der Welt gibt…
Aber die bekommen sie, weil sie eben die Kohle haben.
Natürlich. Diese Attraktivität ist gegeben. Nur die Kohle allein wird inhaltliche Systeme nicht besser machen. Da brauchst du natürlich das geistige Potenzial und die Qualität dazu. Und das passiert gerade mit der Premier League. Das Geld alleine würde mir nicht so viel Angst machen. Mein Problem ist die Qualität der Leute, dass sie sofort erkennen, mit dem Geld dann die Leute auch holen können, aber das Beste auch zu verpflichten. Und gleichzeitig auch national U17 Europameister, U19 Europameister, U20 Weltmeister, U21 erfolgreich. Und das ist auch England. Deshalb gibt es wunderbare Denkweisen. Spanier kann man beobachten, Italiener werden immer besser. Also die Kompetenz des Sports in der Verbindung mit der Wirtschaftlichkeit wird dir helfen. Die reine Wirtschaftlichkeit ohne Kompetenz wird nicht funktionieren, sonst müsste der VfL Wolfsburg nicht unbedingt aktuell wieder um den Abstieg spielen.
Ist da vielleicht die Bundesliga auch ein bisschen Zurückhaltend dadrin, sich selbst Kompetenz aus dem Ausland rein zu holen? Also wenn ich mir angucke, gut Bayern München, Sonderfall, die haben sich sehr früh auf einen deutschsprachigen Trainer festgelegt, aber es ist ja schon eine besondere Situation, dass wir mit Borussia Dortmund Bayern München zwei Vereine haben auf Trainersuche und gefühlt haben, die nur eine Handvoll Kandidaten und richtig erfolgreiche internationale Trainer, die auch zum Teil bei Mannschaften spielen, wo sie noch nicht Champions League spielen. Also in der Primärdivision gibt es hervorragenden Fußball. Warum tut sich die Bundesliga so schwer damit, so jemanden mal hier eine Chance zu geben? Das wäre doch auch für das Produkt Eurosport Player wunderbar, wenn das mal hier ein bisschen durchgemischt würde.
Ich hatte neulich einen Artikel gelesen, da standen die Namen Pep Guardiola, Obameyang, Dembele und einfach noch ein paar weitere. Die waren vor anderthalb Jahren alle noch in der Bundesliga. Warum sind die jetzt weg? Das ist ja gerade so ein bisschen das, dass viele Geld in England gut eingesetzt wird und die Besten dann eben dort rübergehen. Ich glaube, dass wir in Deutschland immer noch so ein bisschen diesen Grundsatz haben, der Trainer muss die Sprache der Mannschaft sprechen. Und über die Sprache und Beispiele war er dann auch wieder mit Ancelotti bei den Bayern. Dass der in der Vergangenheit ein super erfolgreicher Trainer auf einem absoluten Top-Niveau war. Ja, nur, Thomas Müller hatte das bei uns mal in einem Interview erzählt. Dann ist die Mannschaftsbesprechung und es fehlt ebenso dieser Tick der Erklärung oder im zwischenmenschlichen Bereich, wenn ich einfach das in einer anderen Sprache machen muss und die Feinheiten nicht da sind. Ich glaube, dass wenn es beim Branchen Primus dieses Beispiel gab, dass es mit einem ausländischen Trainer, mit einem ausländischen Top-Trainer nicht so gut funktioniert hat, dass dann die anderen nicht nachziehen und die Erfahrungen, die sie gemacht haben – klar, wir hatten viele Holländer, die natürlich dann aber, die sprechen so gut Deutsch, das ist in dem Sinne kein ausländischer Trainer oder jetzt genauso mit Hasen, oder was muss man nicht drüber reden, ist ja gefühlt in Deutsch, oder wenn Lucien Favre bei Gladbach wiederkommen sollte, wie auch immer – dass die Sprache in Deutschland doch noch sehr, sehr hoch eingeschätzt wird und das einfach ein wichtiges Kriterium ist. Also ein Konto von Chelsea, wenn der jetzt in der Bundesliga, also erstmal auch, wo soll er denn hingehen? Also vom Anforderungsprofil her. Wer von ausländischen Top-Trainern kommt denn nach Deutschland? Und dann beschäftige ich mich damit, dass ich dann die Sprache vielleicht lerne. Oli Kahn hat es, glaube ich, gesagt. Als es noch darum ging bei den Bayern, war noch eine Position offen, denk doch mal über Zidane nach. Einfach nur mal so auch dieses Anspruchsdenken. Wen hole ich? Und ich greife mal nach oben in das Regal. Und nicht irgendwo anders. Also bei sämtlichen und bei vielen Vereinen.
Wie wichtig ist es denn da jetzt auch für die Berichterstattung bei Eurosport, dass sich da im deutschen Fußball etwas bewegt? Ich spüre so eine gewisse Müdigkeit bei manchen Fans und auch eine gewisse Müdigkeit bei manchen Journalisten einfach wegen der Art und Weise des Fußballs, wie er gespielt wird, haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, schon ganz gut angesprochen. Aber wie wichtig wäre es denn, dass sich das weiterentwickelt, dass wir wieder vielleicht in der nächsten Saison ein bisschen attraktivere Spiele haben oder zumindest etwas mehr versuchte Offensive? Bei manchen Spielen wirkt es so, es gab mal bei einem alten Computerspiel den Bug, dass wenn der Schiedsrichter angepfiffen hat und der Ball lag am Anschlusskreis und niemand ist hingelaufen, dann wurde das Spiel einfach, dann liefen die 90 Minuten runter. Und ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, dass wenn man die Bundesligisten vorher fragen würde, Herr Tedesco, Herr Hecking, können wir uns auf ein 0-0 einigen und den Ball einfach in die Mitte legen, dass beide sagen würden, super, ich habe meine ungeschlagen Serie ausgebaut, wegen mir können wir das gerne so machen.
Nicht zugelassen. Natürlich nicht zugelassen. Also wir reden auch hier von einem Entwicklungsprozess, wo natürlich erstmal der Mut notwendig ist, um das Gesehene auszusprechen, so auszusprechen, dass es eben analytisch verständlich wird und gleichzeitig glaube ich eben nach wie vor, dass eine insgesamt Kompetenz auch in den Bundesligavereinen, was den reinen Fußball betrifft, sich erhöhen muss. Also viele Mannschaften und viele Bundesliga-Vereine, wenn wir jetzt bei Bayern München sind, Uli Hoeneß, ehemalige Spieler, alles gewonnen. Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, ehemalige Spieler, alles gewonnen. Hasan Salihamidzic, vorher war ich ein bisschen da und zumindest mal gespielt einigermaßen, und Christian Neerlinger. Also da ist Kompetenz in Führungsetagen, was Fußball betrifft, und natürlich aus dieser Situation erst dann mal, natürlich müssen wirtschaftliche Fragen, strukturell, organisatorische Fragen, muss alles ein Bestandteil sein. Zuerst war das ganz einfache Fußballspiel. Zuerst mal war ein Platz, ein Bolzplatz mit zwei Toren. Es war nichts festgelegt, außer dass vielleicht zwei Mannschaften gegeneinander gespielt haben. Alles andere ist ein Bestandteil. Also komm doch wieder da zurück, erkläre das Spiel, wie die Situation ist und alles andere rundherum, wie Marketing, Merchandising, was es alles noch gibt, Auslandsvermarktung, Internationalisierung. Es ist alles gut und schön. Aber wenn ich die Vereine anschaue, in England ist es ein bisschen anders. Da ist der Trainer noch gleichzeitig irgendeine Art Teammanager und der organisiert sich rundherum. Ich finde das immer ein bisschen problematisch. Ein Trainer ist für die Mannschaft verantwortlich, aber für die Strukturen ist ein Verein verantwortlich. Der Trainer ist ein Bestandteil der Struktur. Nicht der Trainer ist die Struktur. Es gibt Konstellationen mit außergewöhnlichen Trainern, der hilft einer schwachen Struktur über ihre Fehler hinweg. Aber das ist für meine Begriffe, es gibt auch nicht den einen Weg. Das, was die Bundesliga verstehen und begreifen muss. Deshalb glaube ich, dass die Bundesliga aktuell in der Strukturierung der Trainer-Thematik eine Entwicklung nimmt, aber in der Sportdirektor-Thematik nicht. Wenn ich sehe, wie die Sportdirektoren-Positionen begleitet und besetzt sind, frage ich mich dann gleichzeitig, was es bedeutet für die Identität des Clubs, für die Idee des Clubs und letztendlich in der Unterstützung für den Trainer, ein Gesicht zu erkennen, was ein Wiedererkennungswert hat. Ich erkenne es nicht, es tut mir leid.
Aber ist da nicht das Problem, dass die aktuell im Rentenalter befindliche Spielergeneration noch aus einer anderen Welt des Fußballs kommt? Denn wenn jemand Anfang der 2000er den Höhepunkt seiner Karriere hatte, der hatte damals noch nicht so viel mit Ernährungswissenschaft, Trainingsdiagnostik, Digitalisierung des Trainings- und Mannschaftsalltags zu tun. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen eine andere Welt.
Ja, aber der Unterschied liegt ja zwischen Aktionismus und Pragmatismus, sage ich immer. Das zu analysieren, wer das können soll, kann ja nur ein Fachmann. Und jetzt frage ich mich aber, wo neben Trainern die absoluten Sportfachleute sind. Und ich bin sogar noch ein bisschen bei ihnen. Manche sind auch zu faul. Aber es gibt auch wieder, ich finde Sebastian Kehl jetzt mit Borussia Dortmund genau richtig zu Akki Watzke und Michael Zorc jemanden dazu zu nehmen, der vor kurzem noch gespielt hat, die Belange, die Bedürfnisse, die Veränderungen mitbekommen, der Ansprechpartner ist und auf diese Stabilität des Clubs punktuell einwirken kann. Nur, die meisten Führungskräfte haben ja Angst, sich Qualität dazuzuholen, weil sie möglicherweise feststellen würden, da haben wir ja in der Vergangenheit oder wie auch immer. Und auch gesellschaftliche Themen wie Streitkultur, wie Ehrlichkeit, wie Vertrauen, wie Verlässlichkeit sind ja auch Bestandteile, mehr Qualität in einem Verein zu haben und damit umgehen zu können. Und deshalb, ich zähle es jetzt nicht auf. Aber gehen Sie doch mal in der Bundesliga durch, wo die Hauptverantwortlichen des Clubs die Kompetenz haben, dass sie mal ein guter Spieler oder ein guter Trainer werden. Aber sie sollen die Spieler beurteilen und die Trainer. Und ich rede nicht, dass es auch den ein oder anderen erfahrenen gibt. Und dass man als guter Trainer genauso eine blöde Diskussion nicht automatisch ein guter Spieler gewesen sein muss. Das ist völliger Blödsinn. Da gibt es auch genug Gegenbeispiele. Aber die Kompetenz muss gegeben sein und in großen Clubs auch nicht nur einseitig. Du musst auch eine Diskussionskultur haben, um die Stärke und damit das Fundament des Clubs zu stärken. Die Bundesliga hat nicht allein Qualitätsprobleme dadurch, dass die Spiele nicht attraktiv genug sind, sondern sie hat ein Thema dahingehend, dass sie sich zu viel hinter Themen versteckt, die mit dem eigentlichen Spiel und dem eigentlichen Leistungsprinzip des Fußballs nichts mehr zu tun haben, sondern Fehlervermeidung und Erklärungsversuche, warum das alles so logisch ist, dass es nicht gut funktioniert. Da sind wir mittlerweile schon Weltmeister.
Aber warum findet dann zum Beispiel so eine Sicht auf die deutschen Bundesliga so selten im Journalismus statt? Das wäre ja eigentlich die Aufgabe der Sportberichterstatter.
Nein, nein, das ist genau das, was ich sage. Wir können doch nicht den Journalisten dafür verantwortlich machen. Und bitte jetzt ganz viel Respekt. Die Journalisten sind Meinungsbilder in Deutschland. In der Regel kenne ich keinen Journalisten, der auf hohem Niveau Fußball gespielt hat, der mal Trainer war, der mal Sportdirektor war oder der einen Verein geführt hat. Und diese Leute sollen die Möglichkeit der Bewertung von Menschen, von Trainern, gehören zu den Menschen, von Vereinen, von Führungspersönlichkeiten fundamental, objektiv, dass das immer subjektiv ist, wissen wir, auch so ein klassisches Ergebnis, bewerten können. Für mich sind das Zauberer. Für mich sind das Zauberer. Es ist unmöglich. Es ist unmöglich. Das Problem ist nur, dass im dem Moment, wo du das ansprichst und die Leute ein bisschen damit konfrontierst, sofort die Haltung kommt, Unverschämtheit, das ist ja, was hat er denn geleistet oder was soll das? Nee, es ist die Wahrheit. Das, was ich nicht selber absolviert habe, aber aufgrund, ich sehe Fußball, Bundesliga, 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre, ach, das legitimiert mich, über Menschen zu urteilen in Personen, wo ich noch nicht mal weiß, wie sich das anfühlt. Ich sage, es sind Zauberer.
Es kann nicht die Aufgabe des Journalismus sein, weil die Substanz nicht vorhanden ist.
Sie wollen es. Sie wollen es gern und sehnen sich auch, wie der Journalist im Allgemeinen, als das Modul des gerechten und des ehrlichen und des richtigen – Die Wahrheit. Es ist nicht möglich. Und im Detail analysiert ist es ein Armutszeugnis. Sie sind jetzt auch ein bisschen auf der Seite. Ich will das gar nicht so sehr angreifen, aber Jan hat das entscheidend gesagt. Ich bin nur deshalb ein bisschen der Meinung, das muss schon noch aus dem Fußball kommen. Und die Berichterstattung ist eine Begleitersteinerung. Ich bin nur ein bisschen sauer, weil die Begleiterscheinung denkt, dass es der Fußball ist und das ist falsch.
Wir haben uns auch missverstanden, denn mir geht es nicht darum, dass die Journalisten jetzt uns die Wahrheit erklären sollen. Wie soll jemand wie ich, der nie Fußball professionell gespielt hat, ich werde nie alle Ebenen dieses Spiels verstehen. Es geht nicht. Ich könnte den Fußballlehrer ausbilden, aber warum werden solche Diskussionen nicht geführt? Wo ist die Streitkultur, die Sie auch im Bezug auf die Vereine angesprochen haben? Wenn ich das, was Sie sagen, auf eine Schlagzeile zusammenfasse, wie ich es überall lese, dann wäre das das Thema Stahlgeruch. Eine Entscheidung wie Hasan Salihamidzic oder Sebastian Kehl wird unter so einem Schlagwort beurteilt. Es gibt nicht einen, der sagt, es ist wichtig, eine Fußballkompetenz auf dieser Ebene mit dabei zu haben. Deswegen darfst du auch gerne noch die Gegenmeinung dazu geben von jemandem, der sagt, jetzt kommt wieder jemand, der vorher noch nie Management gemacht hat und soll Management machen. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, es fehlt diese Kontroverse, und zwar in der sachlichen Diskussion im Journalismus.
Auch das muss erst, genauso wie sich der Fußball gerade wieder weiterentwickelt, von außen beobachtet wurde, muss auch das erst wieder kommen. Und ich glaube, die Diskussion, sie wird kommen. Es ist natürlich dann wiederum die entscheidende Frage, wer führt die Diskussion? Ist dort Substanz dahinter oder ist keine Substanz dahinter? Das ist ja das Entscheidende. Es ist ja genauso bei der, ich kann auch einen ehemaligen Spieler holen, der diesen Stahlgeruch hat, wie auch immer das vom Geruch her ist. Nur, der hat nichts drauf. Das bringt mir auch nichts. Ich brauche einfach Leute, die die Substanz haben und davon gibt es nicht so viele. Es gibt nicht so viele. Ich kann ja jemanden holen, der auch ein ehemaliger Bundesligaspieler war, aber dem ist das wirtschaftlich hier viel wichtiger. Der sagt, für mich ist hier der Umsatz. Wir sind ein mittelständisches Unternehmen und die schwarze Zahn am Ende des Jahres ist wichtig, dass die mit mehr Erfolg vielleicht noch besser dann da wäre. Aber das ist erstmal das primäre Ziel. Also das ist die Besetzung der entscheidenden Posten in den Vereinen, wo die Struktur geschaffen wird. Das ist das Entscheidende. Und wenn dort Leute sind, Freddy Bobic, was hat der in kurzer Zeit in Frankfurt aufgebaut? Das hat der ja nicht alleine gemacht. Der hat ein Team zusammengestellt. Und was haben die für eine, in Anführungszeichen, komische Mannschaft? Also auf die Idee muss man ja erst mal kommen, so viele Nationen da zusammenzupacken. Aber dann hast du den richtigen Trainer dazu, der das inhaltlich und zwischenmenschlich und auch sprachlich regeln kann, weil als Trainer heute mit so vielen verschiedenen Spielern aus den verschiedensten Ländern ist natürlich nicht so schlecht, wenn ich wie Tedesco in Gelsenkirchen fünf Sprachen spreche. Und Nico kommt auch ganz gut klar mit verschiedenen Sprachen. Also darum geht es doch, dieses Team zusammenzustellen von Leuten, die platt gesagt einfach was drauf haben. Davon gibt es nicht so viele.
Und die Voraussetzung, den Fußball zu fühlen, ist nicht die Legitimation, in die Position zu kommen. Fußball, gespielt zu haben, Trainer gewesen zu sein, in eine verantwortliche Position zu gehen, bedeutet erst einmal Leerzeit. Also, aber das war für mich die Grundlage unseres Gesprächs, darüber nachzudenken. Also ein ehemaliger Spieler sofort in eine Führungsposition zu geben, das ist ja Kirre, darüber brauchen wir nicht reden. Aber ihn damit zu konfrontieren, als Verein an sich zu binden und dann die Zeit der Entwicklung in Verbindung zum Erlernen der Grundlagen zu geben, das ist für mich ein Modell, was sich richtig und logisch anfühlt, ist aber nicht das Einzige. Aber darüber sollte man schon mal nachdenken.
Letzte Frage, wir haben jetzt ganz lange über Fußball debattiert und wir könnten wahrscheinlich auch Stunden so weitermachen, aber ist es nicht vielleicht auch manchmal so, dass wir den Fußball zu ernst nehmen? Weil im Grunde sind wir doch eigentlich nur Teil einer großen Unterhaltungsindustrie. Hängt auch ganz viel Geld mit drin, aber um wirkliche Probleme geht es doch im Fußball selten.
Das ist klar. Also das sage ich auch immer, wir haben einen schönen Job, aber keinen wichtigen Job. Wenn wir einen Fehler machen, ja meine Güte, was passiert denn dann? Oder genauso die Fußballer auf dem Platz. Nur, es ist einfach traumhaft. Also es wird auch nicht langweilig. Und es ist ganz einfach, da ist was Rundes in der Mitte und da sind 11 auf der einen, 11 auf der anderen und die wollen das eine in das Netz und der andere in das Netz. Es macht einfach Spaß. Und es macht ja nicht nur wenigen Menschen Spaß, sondern unfassbar vielen. Und einfach diese Begeisterung. Es geht um Emotionen, die transportiert werden und das ist dann wiederum auch wichtig für die Leute. Also um nochmal wieder kurz etwas für Italien. In Italien ist im Moment eine Krise. Den Menschen, denen geht es dreckig, denen geht es schlecht. Arbeitslosenquote enorm hoch. Der Fußball hat dort im Moment auch in einer Stadt wie in Rom einen Stellenwert. Die Leute kommen morgens mit einem Lachen zur Arbeit, weil die Roma gegen Bas-Lohn-Arbeiter gekommen sind. Also es ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Und natürlich ist es eine Unterhaltungsindustrie, aber es ist einfach schön. Es sind Emotionen. Es ist etwas, was einen berührt und was mich mitnimmt und was auch Stimmungen verbessern kann. Also es ist nicht wichtig, wie ein Arzt, wie sonst irgendwas. Da muss man die Relation drin haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite hat das auf jeden Fall seine Berechtigung.
Fußball ist ein Bestandteil der Seele. Liebe, Emotionen, wenn man es denn mag, diese Richtung des Spiels und wenn man es gut findet, wie es andere Sportarten und andere Bereiche des Lebens gibt. Und das berührt die Menschen. Und deshalb ist es so faszinierend. Aber die Vergleiche anzustellen in Themen gesundheitlicher Art und Weise oder was Menschen darüber hinaus leisten können, um einer Gesellschaft zu dienen, der Vergleich hinkt. Weil wir in der Diskussion darüber, Jan hat es gesagt, eines der wichtigsten Bestandteile der Emotion, etwas ist, was uns als Menschen immer geprägt hat. Und die Leidensfähigkeit, die Freude, das ist ein Bestandteil des Lebens und deshalb ist es so wichtig. Und wer es für sich als unwichtig definiert, weil er das dabei nicht empfinden kann, dem gehört genauso unser Respekt.
Ach wunderbar, wenn ich mal wieder einen selbstkritischen Moment habe, ob ich mich wirklich auf den Fußball konzentriere, dann höre ich mir diese letzten fünf Minuten an. Matthias Sammer, Jan Henkel, vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben.
Sehr gerne.
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.